sono un pedagogista e parlerò di Kafka e
in questo grande artista scrittore nel
all'età di 36 anni 5 anni dopo come noto
morirà di tesi in un sanatorio svizzero
galassia in un cassetto senza
pubblicarlo una delle sue tante opere
straordinarie come la metamorfosi il
processo Il Castello
ma non è un racconto non è un romanzo
è la famosa lettera al padre
scrive a suo padre
un importante commerciante di Praga
un importante esponente della comunità
ebraica
la persona
come padre decisamente ingombrante
è lettera al padre un documento pesante
e angosciante
racconta
l'educazione di suo padre
un'educazione svalutante
basata sul giudizio spesso sprezzante di
suo figlio
pieno di insulti
ironia sarcasmo risolini
un modo per schiacciare
il figlio un po' come nel famoso
racconto la metamorfosi alla fine
Kafka chiude
questa lettera
giocata su Tony un po' aggressivi ma
fino a un certo punto con una
dichiarazione ce l'hai fatta papà ce
l'hai fatta termine papà non lo usa però
è questo ce l'hai fatta Sono esattamente
quello che sei riuscito a ottenere con
la tua educazione
sprezzante sono privo di schiena dorsale
sono privo di nervo sono insicuro
per nulla fiducioso nelle mie azioni e
in me stesso al punto che poi le sue
opere più importanti verranno pubblicate
solo da morto
è un documento forte uno dei più
importanti sul tema dell'educazione
ricevuta ossia
sono un pedagogista Quindi so bene che
educare un insieme di metodi sistemi
dispositivi per far crescere il nuove
generazioni c'è la scuola ce la famiglia
società sportive ma
una scarsissima consapevolezza sia sugli
effetti ma sugli effetti di questi noi
Siamo bravissimi a strutturare studiare
Sistemi educativi Ma poi che conseguenze
hanno su chi riceve
Tutto questo a partire da alcune
immagini vedete Questa è
un tema importante ogni epoca la sua
educazione In fondo anche di Kafka non
c'è stata molta considerazione di questa
lettera perché è stata considerata
semplicemente collocata in un certo
contesto storico questo per esempio una
foto della mia educazione siamo Nel 1974
Quindi avevo circa 7 anni al matrimonio
di mio padre che è alla mia sinistra
alla sua destra di mio padre cioè mia
zia Pina che all'epoca era più giovane
dell'attuale Barbara D'Urso
all'epoca non so se avete capito le
persone cercavano di sembrare più
vecchie
contrario di oggi in questa foto non so
se lo notate
se siete avvezzi
all'enigmistica dovreste notarlo c'è un
particolare strano
enigmistico appunto
ve lo rivelo Io così non soffrite troppo
e della mano
e io questa foto per me era il gesto di
tenerezza di mio padre nella sua vita
nei miei confronti
poi guardo meglio la foto come state
facendo voi adesso e cosa scopro che la
mano non tocca la spalla che non c'è
contatto e che quindi Bye bye la
tenerezza
potrei anche io come Kafka scrivere una
lettera a mio a mio padre su questa mano
che non mi tocca no a partire a partire
da questo ma lui era un uomo dei suoi
tempi
i padri dovevano mantenere distanza coi
figli per
strutturare il rispetto l'autorevolezza
doveva essere tutto molto
verticale quindi il fotografo per
benevolenza gli dice Dai no mettigli una
mano sulla spalla fai vedere eccetera
noi non ci riesce
deve recitare quello che gli chiede il
fotografo perché quello
il momento storico
non è semplicemente
una responsabilità individuale però
attenzione attenzione vediamo una foto
dei giorni nostri
tensione Attenzione attenzione Eccola
una foto che trovate
normalmente
su tanti profili Whatsapp
Io ne ho qualcuno dove addirittura la
famigliola sono tutti e quattro con la
boccaccia con i Rolling Stones
eccezionale Uno dice Caspita i tempi
sono cambiati Eh sì sono molto Cambiati
quello che era verticale diventato
orizzontale
quello che era il rispetto è diventato
condivisione
e però secondo voi Secondo noi questa
foto vuol dire che l'educazione è
sparita sarebbe un grave gravissimo
equivoco In realtà questi genitori
stanno creando comunque una forma stanno
modellando i figli e le figlie C'è
comunque
quello che ho definito il copione
educativo che è uno dei miei personali
contributi alla storia dell'educazione e
la storia della pedagogia
che ci permette di andare oltre a
un'idea onnipotente di educazione
cercando di valutare viceversa
l'elemento
passivo ciò che riceviamo quindi
vi leggo questa definizione perché è
necessaria quella forma ricevuta Con
l'educazione che ci segna e in un certo
senso ci definisce
è una Creta che si colloca in un
contenitore ne prende forma ma è come
una pelle ci accompagna tutta la vita
è qualcosa che Indossiamo
permanentemente un modo di vivere
è come dire ciò che abbiamo ricevuto
quando meno
eravamo in grado
di accorgerci che lo stavamo
ricevendo perché semplicemente perché
dei primi quattro anni di vita non ci si
ricorda praticamente nulla E perché
comunque
eravamo in una condizione di dipendenza
un certo senso la natura è benevola con
noi anzi il nostro cervello
eliminando quei ricordi che ci
creerebbero solo un terribile un
terribile imbarazzo e lì però che si
struttura e come sono questi
copioni copioni educativi come li ho
definiti copione educativo e qualcosa
che spesso ci sfugge ma su cui bisogna
costruire
un'interazione se vogliamo evitare di
fare per esempio come questi due
fratelli
i famosi William and Harry
uno il principe designato l'altro lo
scarto
no l'eterna diatriba se non l'eterna
lotta fratricida cui la Bibbia e
quant'altro
ci riportano
senza
nessuna Resistenza
e sappiamo come In questa lotta c'è il
copione della del voler dimostrare di
esserci di valere Ma quanti altri i
copioni tradizionali Adesso vado così
anche
sul banale sul semplice le famose
sorelle William
presidiate militarmente dal padre ma
qualcuno Poi ha suborato che forse anche
il padre era presidiato militarmente
dalla mamma sta di fatto che la loro
vita è segnata dai primissimi anni come
da noi fratelli Inzaghi di Piacenza
ancora oggi il papà di Simone Inzaghi
alle tante interviste che rilascia dice
mio figlio ogni volta che finisce una
partita mi fa una videochiamata per
dirmi come è andata
non so quanti anni ha Simone Inzaghi mi
sembra Ma senz'altro metà della vita è
curioso non lascia dubbi Da dove arriva
tanto ben di Dio calcistico chiamiamolo
così ma ci sono anche i copioni che non
funzionano esattamente come dovrebbero
funzionare copioni aziendali con aziende
portate al fallimento dalla terza quarta
quinta generazione oppure semplicemente
come quello della famiglia Agnelli dove
il povero Eduardo finisce suicida a
circa 40 anni oppure la il copione la
famiglia politica dei Kennedy con
caterve di tragedie
oppure i copioni artistici No il padre
di Mozart
musicista affermato ma solo suo figlio
raggiunge la gloria una Gloria molto
presidiata come un copione dal padre
Idem Picasso il padre pittore importante
ma la Gloria la raggiunge suo figlio una
Gloria pagata caro prezzo dalle sue
donne che hanno lasciato quattro cinque
libri di memoria
terribili
sul grande artista
il copione educativo interessante dei
giorni nostri che vorrei
raccontarvi è quello di Chiara Ferragni
potete anche far finta di non essere
una
seguace di questa influenza Però lei ne
ha 20 milioni
quindi tecnicamente ci sono molte
possibilità che un italiano Almeno su
tre sia un follower In cosa consiste
la sua attività quello di mettersi in
mostra di farsi vedere
con video immagini quant'altro la sua
vita la sua casa i suoi figli
lo dice brava intelligente si è fatta
una storia una carriera un business
caramba Che sorpresa come su cosa
scopriamo sua mamma Marina di guardo
Marina di guardo una scrittrice
scrive romanzi abbastanza
diffusi non ha la fama della figlia però
attenzione perché ci interessa perché in
varie interviste Marina
dichiara
la sua ferita infantili il suo tasto
dolente quello di una bambina
sostanzialmente invisibile che
specialmente suo padre ancora una volta
dava poca importanza a me perché ero
femmina bene sua figlia la senz'altro
riscattata al punto che in ulteriori
interviste Marina di Guarda dice forse è
esagerato perché mi sta oscurando come
scrittrice
succede
il desiderio dei genitori è necessario
crea una tensione e la famosa frase il
famoso verso di Danilo Dolci ognuno
cresce solo se sognato però questo sogno
non deve diventare un incubo
ossia questo sogno non deve diventare
soffocamento
implacabile destinazione finale
perché allora allora come direbbe Donald
Winnicott rischi di fare la vita degli
altri il tragico falso se di cui ci ha
parlato questo grande studioso
non si può quindi eliminare il proprio
copione educativo ce lo portiamo addosso
per alcuni aspetti è davvero una risorsa
ci offre
anche
una base di partenza
una serie di occasioni ma non può
diventare L'essere coppia di qualcun
altro come voleva
il padre di Kafka un figlio forte
nerboruto pieno di energia ma Kafka non
era così
e ha sofferto ovviamente di questo
conflitto ma in questo conflitto Kafka è
ricordato da noi il padre ha ricordato
sono per quella terribile lettera che
gli manda suo figlio Non so se mi spiega
quindi occorre che ciascuno di noi
riconosca il proprio copione educativo è
un invito
non sottovalutate
la forma che han cercato di darvi e
specialmente entrate in conflitto con
questa forma perché per vivere la
propria vita e non quella degli altri e
il conflitto non la guerra il conflitto
che ci permette di creare uno scarto di
crescita uno scarto di consapevolezza un
vero cambiamento E allora vi lascio con
questa frase da comodino o non so dove
la crescita personale non è un'alleanza
Con l'educazione ricevuta non è
agiografia
non l'ho fatta io oggi
con la foto di mio padre invito anche
voi a non farla quanto piuttosto il suo
superamento ognuno di noi
responsabile Nel portare avanti la
storia oltre l'educazione ricevuta
Grazie
[Applauso]